Je suis ici parce que je crois en vous et je
crois en ce programme, monsieur, si vous me permettez, qui
diable est ce type, il est le patron qui
maintient l'ennemi engagé dans les
colonies extérieures, c'est la mission, nous avons la paix
ici, les gens se sentent en sécurité, n'est-ce pas,
je sais  cet ennemi est là je l'ai vu
qu'est-ce que tu attends de moi il y a
un plan en place mais ça va
nécessiter des
choix difficiles le truc avec la guerre ça ne
reste jamais là où tu l'as mis ils sont là
AR
ils sont chez eux  des millions de
personnes, c'est mon travail de décider quoi faire
ensuite, il s'agit de contrôler qui
dicte la façon dont cette guerre est
menée